welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the falcon in the winter
soldier has concluded by confirming sam
wilson as the new captain america
a promotion marvel is so confident about
that they announced a fourth captain
america film
now in the works following sam wilson
the cap too cool for headgear
which i think by sam's logic makes him a
sorcerer not a wizard think about it now
this doesn't mean that we're done with
steve rogers in the mcu
there has been some reporting that a
separate chris evans caps spin-off is
still in development
and the falcon of the winter soldier
left us enough clues to tell us what the
future of captain america could look
like
so i'm gonna break down the two major
possible paths forward so the finale
episode revealed sam in his new captain
america suit courtesy of the wakandans
combining design elements from past
capped suits including the shield
magnetically latching onto his back
which has got to be annoying to deploy
red wing now but we all had to learn
with being unable to simultaneously
charge our iphones and use wired
headphones
so i guess sam can take it up with shuri
at the next wakanda con anyway its
upgrades include two red wing drones
that sam uses as thrusters though we
should point out he did manage to hold
up that truck for like 10 seconds on the
power of its core thruster alone
and when the drone latches it forms the
shape of the letter
a for a i look pretty cool don't i
also america of course this is
reminiscent of the way tony stark used
his mark 47 armor and detachable
thrusters to push a staten island ferry
back together in spider-man homecoming
though i would argue grc diplomats are
equally unworthy of saving as ways in
and out of staten island but that's just
me
sam's new wings are made of wakandan
vibranium forming an interlocking seal
with the vibranium shield protecting
from that crashing helicopter
so really in this fourth cap film we are
looking at a sam wilson captain america
with the combined functionality of the
previous captain america
and iron man and black panther meanwhile
this series set up joaquin torres to be
the new falcon as he does in the comics
when sam becomes cap episode 1 shows him
eagerly reaching in to help sam repair
red wing you could try to reroute that
together would you not
oh in episode 5 sam left his broken
wings with torres to repair
wait yo you forgot the wings cable
which seems like what tories is in the
middle of doing while he watches sam's
speech to the grc leaders
now it's less clear if bucky would join
sam in this new cap film
the writers revealed that the reason sam
and bucky didn't appear together in
episode 1 was because kevin feige
apparently wanted to make the two remain
their own independent entities for
future separate stories
a bit of a weird reason for a show where
the characters are part of a titular duo
but whatever
but a reminder episodes three and four
explored bucky's whole relationship with
the wakandans as the white wolf
something that we could see more of in
black panther too but really the
question is what threat or conflict or
dilemma or crisis will sam wilson
captain america face
well there were two moments in the
finale episode that presented coming
conflicts on the marvel horizon
power broker sharon carter tells her
buyers to get ready for the government
secrets and the prototype weapons she
will now have access to
this really positioned sharon as a key
player in the upcoming series armor wars
focusing on the weaponry of the mcu
falling into the wrong hands
starring rhodey and sharon's trading
partners could include
all of mcu weapons dealers including
hydra the 10 rings
aim hammer sonny burch's mysterious
buyer from ant-man the wasp
rocket raccoon even oscorp like i
pointed out how sharon's chemical
weapons and the ones that she supplied
to batroc to give to the flag smashers
do resemble the designs of norman
osborne green goblin or even the kind of
things otto octavius might design
as of now we're not really certain what
logic sony will use to justify doc ox
return in spider-man no way home
but we did get a clue from another shady
character in the falcon the winter
soldier contessa allegra valentina de
fontaine which for some reason she
doesn't want us to shorten to val
she worked with zemo from his
imprisonment on the raft to assassinate
the remaining flag smashers
and suited up john walker as u.s agent
and a plot that i believe could be
inspired by the thunderbolts initiative
or the dark avengers and she told jon
things are about to get weird so
when they do we're not going to need a
captain america
[Music]
we're going to need a u.s
agent really a lot of this comes down to
what thou
meant by the word weird but before we
continue are you carrying a credit card
balance month after month like your will
smith and independence day dragging that
alien through the desert
high interest rates make it hard to pay
off your debt but upstart can help
join the thousands of happy borrowers
who made that final payment
upstart is the fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt
all online over half a million people
have used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment with a 5 minute online
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans from 1 000 to 50
000 loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit your income and
other info that you provide in your loan
application
you can get approved the same day and
can receive funds as fast as one
business day
let go of that alien body it's hard
enough just walking through the desert
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
new rockstars that's upstart.com new
rockstars don't forget to use our url
and let them know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit your income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application
go to upstart.com new rockstars as a
shadowy government agent with higher
than normal security clearance she could
be referring to the coming secret
invasion by the skrulls who have shown
up in captain marvel spider-man far from
home
one division and soon loki far from home
actually referred to a cree skrull
shadow war going on during this period
i thought cree having sleeper cells was
top secret information nick
if val was talking about scrolls that
could give a greater weight to this
whole conspiracy theory that steve
rogers might be on the moon
like whatever shuttle took nick fury to
earth's orbit and with all the skrulls
could have also taken steve
in fact steve could be the person that
squirrel agent was referring to when she
told monica rambo
someone wanted to meet her up there if
this is the weirdness ahead in the mcu
sam's next mission as captain america
could revolve around him being a beacon
of trust in an era of the secret
invasion
when no one can be trusted and his cap 4
film might be set in an mcu where old
man steve rogers and nick fury are
looking down on him from
earth's orbit but there is another
interpretation of the word weird because
val had also said
there's a little dirty state secret
it doesn't really belong to the
government it's kind of a legal gray
area
which i think might refer to the fact
that this shield was technically brought
to sam
from old cap who according to the
endgame directors
comes from an alternate timeline and so
that shield
is legally the property of an alternate
timeline government
i just bring this up because we know the
mcu is headed to some multiverse event
with one division's post-credits scene
showing the scarlet witch using the dark
hole to peer into the multiverse setting
up her return in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and loki now
appears to be establishing the rules
of branch timeline logic in the mcu a
multiverse collision might be that
weirdness ahead
and the logic that sony uses to justify
the roles of doctor strange and alfred
molina dock and jamie fox electro in no
way home
and oscorp could indeed be one of the
power brokers trading partners
the multiverse could also mean the chris
evans cap spin-off could be set
in that alternate timeline with steve
and peggy carter actually sharon's
post-credits scene did make two
references to peggy
carter's name has always been synonymous
with service trust
welcome home agent carter the upcoming
what if first episode that explores what
if peggy carter got the serum could be a
kind of test for a future live-action
alternate timeline plot following these
two during the cold war
all while back in our prime mcu timeline
captain america sam wilson has to deal
with multiversal arrivals like
captain britain brian braddock a name
referenced in
endgame
[Music]
look the multiverse is definitely weird
but it is kind of weird that i'm ready
for but i want to know from you what
conflict do you see in
sam's future as captain america the
secret invasion or
a multiverse collision hey by the way
our anarchy assembled shirt is still
available
along with our other amazing zemo design
though we are running low on
both of those so yeah gotta move fast
you can support us this way at
newrockstarsmerch.com
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea boss follow new rockstars
and subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of that very thing marvel
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you